[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: This is I/O
Live, and I'm Timothy Jordan.
And we're here in the
Google Assistant Sandbox.
I'm going to go
find Wayne, who's
going to give us a little tour.
What do you say?
Hey, Wayne, that was convenient.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: I was
just here waiting for you.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I'm
glad that you were.
So there's a lot going
on in the sandbox,
and you're just going to take us
around and tell us what's what.
Give us all the new stuff.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: So we have
a look going on right now.
I mean, one of
the biggest things
we announced at CES this year
was these new smart displays
that we've got.
So the Assistant
is now no longer
just an audio experience.
It's now a display experience.
It runs on these smart displays.
It runs on phones, Android
Wear, Android TV, Android Auto.
It's kind of everywhere.
So there's a lot of
new possibilities
for the Assistant, and there's
over 500 million devices that
now have the Assistant on it.
So it's definitely a
platform that everyone
should be building for.
And, yeah, we've got a
bunch of cool demos here.
We've got my friend
Kenny over here,
who's an expert in this demo.
So let's see what we
can do with this tablet.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hey,
how are you doing.
KENNY LAI: Good, how are you?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I'm doing
very well, thank you.
Do you want to show us a demo?
KENNY LAI: Yeah, so
today we're going
to show how users can interact
with our new smart displays
to do something cool,
such as a cooking app.
Hey, Google, ask Tasty how to
bake brownie cheesecake cookie.
So you can see, this is very
similar to a tablet experience,
except we consider this
voice-first in that we
want users to always interact
with this using their voice.
You can interact by
tapping on the display.
But as a user, you're cooking.
Your hands are dirty.
You don't want to be
getting your devices dirty.
So you can also interact with
this completely hands-free.
Hey, Google, skip to step 10.
So as you can see,
this gives the user
another option of
interacting with their Google
Assistant They can be
busy with their hands.
They do not have to use their
hands at all to control this.
And they can still get all the
information that they need.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's awesome.
Thank you.
KENNY LAI: Yeah, you're welcome.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All
right, Wayne what's next?
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Yeah, so here
we've got our website here,
which is our Actions Discovery
Area, where consumers
can find out more about
the kinds of things
that they can do with
Actions on Google.
There's over a million
different actions that
are made by Google or by
third party developers,
just like everyone
watching this show,
that they can make and
then make available on here
so their consumers can
find out what's available.
So you see, you can do
things like buying tickets,
ordering flowers, all kinds
of things appearing here.
There's this huge directory
of all different categories
that people can
look in to find out
about the things they can do.
So there's lots of
different things.
I have a suspicion you probably
could live in your house
and just do everything
with your voice
now without even having
to lift a finger to eat,
and do things, and
order, and whatever.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: It let's
you do other things, too.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI:
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK,
what else is next?
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: So here
we've got Android Wear,
which you mentioned earlier.
And then also we have
our Google Home Max,
which is a big subwoofer-based
speaker that's really loud
booming audio for big rooms.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
What's next?
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Say
hello to Dialogflow.
This is our tool
that allows people
to build conversational actions
and experiences for the Google
Assistant.
It makes it really easy
to use machine learning.
So basically you train it
with some example sentences.
And then the next thing you know
you've built a conversation.
We've actually been giving
talks where in five minutes
we build a booking
action, and show you
how to build an
appointment system,
and how to extract dates
and times from people.
It makes it really easy
to build conversations.
This is probably one of
the most important tools
when it comes to
building fractions
on Google and the
Google Assistant.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
Let's check out one more area.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: So now I've got
Glen from Google Assistant SDK
team to show us some really
cool demos they're working on.
GLEN SHIRES: Yeah, so with
the Google Assistant SDK,
we can put the Google Assistant
into any device with a speaker
and a microphone.
For example, you may want
to put it into a microwave
oven or a set-top box.
We decided that for the show
we'd have a little bit of fun
and put it into a plotter.
PLOTTER: Hey, Google,
let's make some art.
GLEN SHIRES: So what
we're seeing here
is a couple of different things.
First of all, we have
the plotter talking
to the Google Assistant.
And everything this
guest is saying
is going up to the
cloud, being processed,
and it can answer regular
commands, such as,
tell me the weather.
But in addition to that,
we've layered custom commands
on top of it, such as
draw purple triangle.
It makes it a lot easier
and a lot more customizable
for people to build
applications that
are built into appliances,
set-top boxes, cars,
almost anything.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
Thank you so much, Glen.
GLEN SHIRES: Thank you.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Wayne, thanks so much.
If developers want to get
started, where do they go?
WAYNE PIEKARSKI:
Yeah, no worries.
So the best place to go is
developers.google.com/actions
and get started with Actions
on Google built for the Google
Assistant.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
If you'd like to check out
some more videos like this,
go to g.co/io/guide.
And if you'd like to catch
any of the sessions from I/O,
g.co/io/videos.
Let's get out of here.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Let's go, man
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
See you all later.
[MUSIC PLAYING]